welcome to CBS this morning we began
with some sad news it's a plane crash
and the cause of that plane crash that
killed 10 people near Dallas is still a
mystery at this hour one day after the
accident the private aircraft crashed
into a hangar and burst into flames
shortly after takeoff yesterday two crew
members and eight passengers were killed
this morning you can see a gaping hole
in that hangar the plane was supposed to
go to Florida
Mireya Vieira L is at the scene in
Addison Texas about 15 miles north of
Dallas Maria what else do we know about
the crash well we know right now is that
this small plane is often used for
business flights witnesses say they saw
the plane take off and then come
crashing down after it lost altitude
into the hangar the privately owned
hangar that you see behind me it looked
like that hangar might be two different
colors but that middle shiny area is
actually scorch marks left behind from
this accident massive flames and thick
black smoke poured from the hangar at
the Addison County Airport Sunday
morning everybody we had a ya accident
on the field
a small private airplane plunged into a
hangar at 9-11 a.m. killing all 10 on
board we know that there were two flight
crew members and that there were eight
passengers we don't have a lot of detail
beyond that the twin engine Beechcraft
was taken off for st. Petersburg Florida
witnesses say it lifted off the runway
reaching about 200 feet when it began
losing power and altitude the plane that
veered left and dropped its left wing
before crashing into the hangar the
airplane was damaged by impact forces
and a post-impact fire NTSB officials on
the ground are combing through debris
for any clues to what caused the crash
anytime there's a significant fire
situation in this case it does pose more
of a challenge for the investigators
aviation expert captain Laura ein
settler says officials will be
considering all possible causes
including engine failure pilot error or
weight issues it's ten passengers plus
fuel plus a lot of possible luggage
could also play a role in the aircraft
performance if they did say lose an
engine
or something on takeoff it's still
unclear who actually owns this
particular plane because there's a
little confusion with the tail number
right now what we do know is the
previous owner was a charter company out
of the Chicago area the NTSB could take
up to a full year for their full
investigation but a preliminary report
could be ready and as early as two weeks
Tony
yeah thank you very much